foreign
Ohio and talk to Mel what's up Mill
hey good morning Dr John good morning to
you how are you
I'm good what's up
I'm
so I'll lead with my question I'm a
little nervous I am too I'm super nice I
should be taking that anxiety test right
about now
the results of your anxiety test would
be talking to a not very talented middle
of the road podcaster and asking life
wisdom so that's what it would tell you
all right my question is how do I know
the difference between my nervous system
response that seems to Drive the ship
hijack everything and what is a true
sense my gut my my intuition and my
knowing
um why does let me ask you this why do
you think there needs to be a difference
um because I feel like like I've
operated from a place where you know
everything is a threat
okay but what if everything is a threat
yeah
you're assuming your body's wrong what
if your body's right
is it
um
I'm coming to the place where I you know
I've been so disconnected from my body
for so many years and I finally taking
it seriously my youngest son looked at
me one day he's five years old and said
Mommy why are you such an angry woman
and you know it stopped me in my track
was he right
oh it is I am yeah yeah she was right
who disconnected you from your body
what happened
oh
um
no chaotic house parents who were my
parents were adult children of
Alcoholics
um they had no you know they just didn't
know what they were doing and building a
business building a very successful
um it was just I was on my own
some sexual abuse when I was beyond but
just always feeling that I was
and there's just no like I'm really we
grew up more like employees than
children I think hey when you
experienced
um that sexual abuse did you tell
anybody when you're a kid no
okay all right
and that's that's that that's nothing to
be ashamed of
um I was just wondering if you told
somebody and they didn't believe you or
they didn't respond but almost worse is
you were left completely on your own
and I knew there was nowhere to tell I
mean there was no
at that age you know it's a very young
age but hold on there's another side to
that
there should have been
and Trauma can be what happened to you
and Trauma can also be what didn't
happen to you and should have 100
percent
and Trauma like the way Dr mate just
like defines it and I love it trauma is
simply a disconnection from yourself
and I hate that for you
I don't think there's a difference
between your nervous system and your gut
I think they're both trying to keep you
safe because the people that were
supposed to keep you safe were too too
interested in their business
and too interested in trying to
learn new tools for how what a
relationship should look like since
their parents didn't have any
and you had a little girl dealing with
sexual abuse and dealing with isolation
and loneliness and
being left behind for work
and that little girl went and got
married and had kids right
well we're not married we've been
together 15 years and I still don't
marry him why
I don't know
you do why not I'm proud but I don't I
just
oh
why don't you think you are worth that
security
and I know it's cool to say like because
we're all moderate and hip like I don't
even need that bro this is like I don't
need a piece of paper to tell me
I've been saying that for years
what's that protecting you from
I think the disappointment if it doesn't
work out there you go
15 years
it's a long time
three kids we have two kids together I'm
raising a beautiful bonus kid from a
previous relationship he has and we have
a beautiful life we have would he marry
you would he marry you tomorrow
right like this week I'm not sure
hey I I just realized I've just been
talking
I heard my friend Mel
really unsure of Mel
I don't even know why you called yet but
I just want to take some time at the
beginning of this call to tell you you
may not believe in you but I do
and I think I'm building that I've
really been intentional I've lost 75
pounds
smokes that's amazing I'm sitting
sitting in the white parking lot right
now
um
yeah wow that's awesome
a good enough therapist not great but
hey that's what I am I'm good enough I'm
not a therapist but good enough YouTube
and then I I have a life coach and I my
partner and I went to the summit of
greatness a couple weeks ago here in
Columbus I was just with Lewis uh in Los
Angeles last week awesome guy yeah yeah
there's this part of me that you know
and as I
I thought I had processed all my trauma
and all my stuff I've been you know kind
of doing that for years but I've numbed
out with a lot of things over the years
um
you know our problems in our
relationships certainly aren't one-sided
I guess they never are
but um how can I help you today
[Applause]
I mean you answer my question that I got
in my my intuition don't have to be or
my nervous system don't have to be two
separate things
I think it's fear and just taking that
chance but my girls looked at me one day
and they're like Mom we're never getting
married and we're never having kids yeah
we have 12 years and 13 years old
and
you know what we've shown them what I've
shown them what it is to be
[Applause]
and now to complete that thought because
it just hits me in my
I think I think I think when you start
to get well you start to
I'm going to send you a copy of my new
book building an unanxious life but I I
pre-ordered it oh you did honestly you
know the one how about that I appreciate
I appreciate you doing that
um
but the first thing you have to do is
you have to choose reality here's the
truth of my life
these things happen to me these are the
choices I'm making and the work you've
been doing going to counseling
um
really honoring yourself being such a
good Steward of Mel losing 75 pounds
that's amazing
spending money
with your 15-year boyfriend
father of your kids going to like
something great like the summit of
greatness with Lewis and his in his gang
like that's awesome but what it does is
it kind of it it serves as
a refining fire and it burns off all the
access nonsense and what you are sitting
with
is reality
you've been pretending you're not
married for 15 years you're as married
as the day is long
you're pretending that you're safe
because you're not in under some
Covenant yet you've created humans
and what you're starting to see of the
reality of your life is you've lived
your whole life with one foot out of the
boat to protect you
and in so doing your kids don't have a
stable place a firm foundation to stand
on
the guy who's your husband probably
legally at this point
um also doesn't have a firm place to
stand on
and by the way all this work you've been
doing you go to something like the
summit of greatness it should shake you
up you leave really pumped up and you go
home and you look at your house when you
walk in the door from a trip like that
and you go Ah that's right that's good
because now your next thing is I gotta
start making these changes that I
learned about and I've been learning
about
and I'll say this I don't think your
nervous system is wrong I think it's
doing what it was just what it grew
to do which is to protect you
but it's protecting you something from
something now that doesn't exist anymore
and that is somebody who's abusing you
that is somebody who's neglecting you
unless I'm Wrong Am I Wrong
no there's definitely neglect in this
relationship okay
so maybe able to express what I need
what my needs are why not
hyper independent hold on hold on hold
on you're not able to express them
because you're gonna get hit in the
mouth
you're not able to express them because
your husband's a child and he'll go
drink six beers and leave you for a
weekend or you're not able to express
them because you choose not to say them
out loud
that and if I I have expressed my my
needs in the past and it turns into a
you know he might disappear for a day or
a week or
um a little stonewalling so maybe let's
Circle all the way back to the beginning
when you just started talking and I just
felt in my guts I needed to interrupt
you maybe your body's right this is not
a guy to marry
if a man can make two babies with a
woman and she can't say hey I need this
without him throwing a temper tantrum
and taking off for a day
it's not safe
it means you're dating a child literally
a child trapped in a man's body and
if I'm him
and I'm watching the woman that I love
drown
because she still has chains around her
feet and arms and shoulders and waist
from when she was six years old
and she won't tell me how to help
it's exhausting it's so frustrating
because he feels useless
that's it and he tries to help he
doesn't know how
and your daughters see this ping-pong
match between you two and they're like I
don't want any part of that and you know
intuitively they're gonna miss out on
the best part of life which is finding
somebody
and you look at them and say I'm all in
if you are not somebody perfect not the
quote unquote the one because that's not
real but someone who says I'll I'm in if
you are and they go all right
and that's the best part of life and the
part that gets you hurt the most because
you expose yourself the most to that
person but they've said I don't want to
do that
and what they did was they held a mirror
up to you and you were able for the
first time after this healing to see
wait a minute I'm worth more than this
too
is that fair
do you believe you're worth more than
that because I do
I do I I didn't for a long time and I
spent a lot of time
a lot of things
I'm so proud of you
and like every single person I've ever
sat with
from high school kid to under
undergraduate to graduate students to
parents to
elderly folks who just lost their spouse
I asked the same question we get to this
moment what are you going to do now
you want me to give you some starters
yes
star number one is to tell I'm just
going to call him your husband because I
don't play those kind of games
um
you're gonna tell your husband
you and I on Saturday
we're going out for a half day
because I I've been doing a lot of
counseling I've lost 75 pounds you lost
my daughter
I know it's amazing
um
and I she's always like that piggyback
ride piggyback ride and just going up
and down the stairs two or three times I
work out a lot too much
and even I'm like man I need you to get
down get off it's too heavy you lost my
daughter
yeah
and you've been going to counseling not
a great counselor but a good enough
you're investing yourself and I think
you I want you to tell your husband I
want to go spend a few hours
for the first time ever
looking out to 2033
and saying we're we're gonna be at 2033
whether we want to or not and my
daughter's going to be 23 years old and
22 years old
and we have an opportunity right now to
build the life that we want when they're
22 and 23. are they going to want to
come home
are we going to be talking about some
hot new things she's dating and she's
planning a mayor a wedding what or we're
gonna do be doing something else but you
get to decide that
I want you to tell them
we need to have some hard conversations
about truths if you're not attracted to
me anymore I need you to bring that with
you if you don't want to be with me
anymore I need you to bring that with
you
I'm going to bring what I need and I
can't have you running away
and you just stay present with me even
when he gets hard
and if he says I ain't doing that then
you've heard me say this on the show a
bunch Behavior's a language
then he's telling you I'm not interested
in you growing
I'm not interested in you getting well I
liked my old life where I felt Superior
to you because you were 75 pounds
heavier than you are now I liked my old
life
when I could complain about everything
before you started going to trauma
counseling and healing
when one person in a relationship like
this starts doing a lot of work on their
own it disrupts the equilibrium of the
home the homeostasis it changes the
dynamic of everything and sometimes
without meaning to the other partner
will try to bring the other person back
somebody loses 75 pounds and all of a
sudden someone's like let's just order a
pizza
showing up with donuts on a Saturday
morning they get up really early they
put gas in your car for the week and
they go grab a dozen donuts just because
yeah you've been working so hard
it's this weird subconscious thing I
need things back the way they were even
though back the way they were I didn't
like it I wasn't comfortable my partner
was sick all the time I didn't no one
was comfortable
we're just there
and so to keep that thing from getting
dragged back from keep you from getting
pulled back or just getting shot out
like a rubber band this whole thing's
over 15 years three kids it's all just
over
it's important to just go take some time
change the environment change the
location and say let's be adult let's
put everything on the table and let's
make a choice are we going to build
something new
are we going to keep building something
new
or
is my body telling me the truth this is
not somebody who's safe to be with long
term this is not somebody to build a
life with and I've been playing for the
last decade
and I think you look across the table in
a very scary vulnerable way probably
more vulnerable than you've been since
you were a young little kid
and you say this is what I need and this
is where I want to go
do you still love me and will you still
be here because he might say no
but
he might say yes
and so goes love and so goes marriage
and so goes romantic relationships
do you see all of me
and do you see where I want to go and do
you see who I'm becoming and
do you still love me too
you're worth it Mel you're worth it
write down the questions you want to ask
him write down your needs
invite him to a dreaming breakfast and
lunch
call me back after that meeting I'll be
here with you every step of the way I'm
so so proud of you
the hard work is still to come
but man you have launched out like a
rocket